Yard House is like in a big California
mall it's like a massive place where
people can go get like beers you can get
like an onion ring Tower and you can get
like you know tuna tartar
wontons or something it's like that type
of restaurant you go you get like tuna
tartar nachos
you get like a um yeah there it is pull
that up make that big right there make
that big that's what yard house is make
it big make it bigger I want to see it
big
this is your house but what is this it's
the video hold on I don't want the video
we don't want the video I just want to
see see that's what yard house is
there's a woman there she's got a
massive uh a beer she's got some type of
dip in front of her and she's got I
guess make it smaller so we can see the
onion rings
she's got a tower of onion rings
because that's what your yard house is
for people that when you put on your
rings and Tower they go oh yeah
that's that's what yard house is for
it's for when the onion rings
hit the table and they're in a tower it
makes someone's day
and make someone's day and then they
just have things on the menu for no
reason they'll have like garlic shiitake
garlic noodles
look at you fancy pants you're having
shiitake garlic noodles it's 111 degrees
out you're in Palm Desert California
you're in the yard house and you're
eating shiitake garlic noodles
and thinking about how much money it's
gonna cost for your divorce how cool is
that
Yard House is for people who who've just
been denied alone
that's where you go after you've just
been denied alone and you're like well I
can still eat good here
it's when your bank calls you and goes
there's nothing really we can do
at this point taking a new account like
you can hear the bank saying it as they
wait on the line like you can like you
can hear like the bank being like taking
into account the income and the credit
they're like two two please yeah yeah
what what so taking into account the
income and the credit we're not able to
proceed with the car loan of six
thousand dollars they go all right all
right I understand [__] all right well
I'm gonna have to onion ring Tower and
the tuna tartar uh the Tuna the Tuna
spicy tuna whatever you put that on what
do you put it on a pizza just bring it
to the table give me a big uh cold beer
and a fat Hispanic woman if you can't
just bring out a fat Hispanic woman with
two children a cold beer and then a
tower of onion rings if you can because
but I like yard house because I like it
knows what it is there's certain
restaurants that know what they are
they're like let's make the food into
gimmicks because the people that eat
here don't have much like and they're
not here's the other thing Yard House
the people that eat in Yard House are
not broke it's not like Popeyes in a bad
area it's like Yard House so what it is
people who are playing this game of
America they're in the game
but it's not great
the ball's hitting them
they're not reacting that's what yard
house is for people that are in the game
people that are trying to sell a 2019
Chevy Silverado
hmm
because they need something
are eating at yard house that's who eats
at Yard House people that are in the
game they're not
totally destitute they're not living on
the street they're not an intent they're
not on fentanyl they're not [__] in
a Whole Foods
but they're trying to make very small
moves
to better themselves
and they're doing it at a yard house
because that's a place they can let
loose
have a couple of beers watch the game
and think about how
they're going to come up with the money
to euthanize their dog
because that's what that restaurant's
about it's about figuring out how to
move money around so you have enough
money to put your dog down
Yard House
get the menu up and you are and I can I
can prove this when you read the menu
you go this is where I would go and I
like by the way I like Yard House many
times in my life I've been a Yard House
person
I've gone to Yard House go to the
appetizers
appetizers coconut shrimp
onion ring Tower
jumbo Bavarian pretzel
this is a study of what people in this
country will eat the lower middle class
grilled Korean barbecue beef
Wisconsin fried cheese curds
avocado toast calamari there's no theme
to Yard House by the way
the theme of the foodie Yard House is
anything you've heard of
anything you've heard of and nothing you
haven't sweet potato fries snacks I like
that they have an appetizer section and
a snack section because it's like you
might want a snack in between the
appetizer and the entree
Stacks guacamole truffle fries sweet
potato fries edamame shiitake garlic
noodles who doesn't want a big bowl of
garlic noodles as a snack these are just
Foods you've heard of that's what yard
house is it's Foods you've already heard
of but they're here in the mall
We're Not educated it's not like would
you like some Arctic char what no it's
would you and what is this Garden
everything there's gardein with a little
r Garden Wings Garden orange chicken
pizzas they got pizza too they have
something called The Vampire
a cheese
curated tortilla Carnitas bacon roasted
garlic crushed avocado none of it makes
sense
sour cream cilantro it's just things
you've heard of
things you've heard of on a plate come
to Yard House we won't challenge you
you like noodles
you'll get noodles so what is this
Garden it says it's a chicken substitute
made from soy wheat oh nice
meatless
but I like yarn I like yard house I'll
go to Yard House right [__] now
and I'll talk to a divorced substitute
teacher
whose son is severely autistic and she
wants a white zinfandel and she needs an
onion ring Tower
stop
because her husband became trans and
joined the military
Yard House is just a collection of
simple tragedies at the yard house it's
not even it's people that you can't
really feel bad for either when they
start talking you go oh
can't really feel bad for you kind of a
terrible person you're dumb
but it's like the Yard House when people
start telling you the problems you're
like oh you've gone further than you
should have you've gone it'll be some
guy who's like I invested with my
brother
in a company that turned out not to have
existed and and then like he'll start
screaming like five minutes in about
like the border and I was like it's the
[__] border they're coming over here
I'm like wait what you lost all your
money with your brother you idiot he's
like yeah whatever can I have some carne
asada garlic noodles I don't know what
it is but I've heard of it can I have a
Bavarian pretzel and an avocado toast
they have avocado toast can I have a
Bavarian avocado toast pretzel please
and some [__] Korean beef
I want some Korean beef and a vampire
I hope this is played
at every Yard House every worker at a
Yard House
every Yard House worker
because it's like sometimes attractive
women kind of
um
people that are excited like a few of
them have said oh where fans of your
work so
I appreciate that but you get what I'm
saying here you understand what I'm
saying Yard House Foods you've heard of
you're in a mall anyway you're here
anyway Yard House basically like you're
in a mall anyway these are foods you've
heard of you cannot afford your children
you cannot afford your children come to
your house have get your children a
pizza and sit there and think about how
you're going to get yourself under get
yourself out from under this mountain of
debt and horrible decisions that you've
made in this disgusting restaurant where
you're just eating fat and sugar you get
in your car you have a headache you're
like I'm full in a weird way I don't
feel good I'm having a panic attack
should I go to the hospital nope can't
afford that just keep driving just keep
driving with your your face covered with
Yard House glaze whatever [__] sick
disgusting sugar glaze they toss
everything in you're just like oh
you go back to your house
they can barely afford you put the kids
in front of the TV they're all on drugs
they're all trans you're happy about it
you don't care
you're trying to get money from the
government you go can I get money from
the government if they're trans your
wife goes shut up
you go to Yard House
if you go to Yard House again stop
trying to make our kids trans get money
from the government did you have a
Bavarian pretzel at noon you sick [__]
it's a disgusting place but I like it
Tim